okay how did we mean it well we met back
to John's question okay actually we met
and I had forgotten this but you came on
a tour mm-hmm and in in my diary I kept
the diary in those days I mentioned John
something about remember his last name
came up from Disney he was the only one
that seemed really interested in what we
were doing but then we reconnected later
on the Queen Mary and at that time we
didn't know why but John was actually
looking for something else and we wanted
to bring in a real animator up to
Lucasfilm so that we could continue to
develop develop a technology our dream
was to make a computer animated film and
John it turns out at Disney had
experimented with computer animation
with a company blue sky right no man I
sent the vision oh man that's right yeah
they went to blue sky right had already
done some experimenting so he had this
excitement about using this new
technology and that's what we wanted
somebody had this drive to do it and to
be honest we were just thinking in terms
of an animator having no idea of course
what his long-term potential was the in
so Edie it hired me into the Lucas home
computer division and we should maybe I
don't know that people take for we take
for granted I know what it is how
groundbreaking the work that was going
on there things I'm gonna brag about
Edie for a second okay I'm George Lucas
hired him in 1979 from nears New York
Institute of Technology to develop for
insane well actually three and then Edie
brought the fourth one with him really
crazy insane ideas and projects one to
edit a movie using a computer digital
nonlinear editing and to digital sound
editing number three the digital
compositing of images at number four was
computer animation from 1979 through
1986
we were about what forty people at the
forty people invented those four
concepts and things without these you
don't have the avid you don't have
digital editing which is which is the
standard you don't have digital comp but
you don't have pro tools all of this
stuff came from there's a big bang that
goes on here and in researching this I
didn't I never realized the significance
and without this this butter line
butterfly wing flap we would still be
doing things like we were doing them 40
years ago so this is the significance of
it the vision that George had and then
that also that I think that the
understanding the talent and what your
abilities were and collecting those
people together that was really the the
formation of the many things besides
just Pixar George is the only one in the
industry willing to pay it was we're
pretty interesting they're quite
conservative but George after Star Wars
realized the technology was playing a
role in what he was doing so he funded
it when nobody else would it was
remarkable that that it was out of his
own money that he in fact it was
interesting because we've had both
George Lucas and Steve Jobs that funded
the development of what we did out of
their own pocket two very remarkable
people that that bought into this vision
and it was our great fortune to line up
with him so I came up to start working
with with Ed and then looked some
computer division it was December of
1983 I had been trying very hard at the
well Disney Animation Studios to to
interest interest them in doing applying
computer animation technology to Disney
animation they had in fact bill crier
worked on Tron and which was Disney had
produced and it was using one of the
first in major motion pictures to use
significant amounts of computer
animation and it was so mind-blowing to
me and it seemed like the natural thing
I was I always felt like this is what
what was waiting for the he was
constantly striving to get more de
menthe
in his animation you know with the
multi-plane camera and so on he
experimented with stop-motion animation
but it didn't have the same control over
timing as hand-drawn animation so when I
saw computer animation it it was like a
bell went off in my head and I said this
is it this is what what was waiting for
true three-dimensional animation with
the control of hand-drawn animation and
I was hooked and I knew that this was
the future but it was having a hard time
convincing Disney at the time to to be
interested in it and so that's when I
met Edie and so he invited me to come
work with him and so so when I got there
as John mentioned it had gathered the
greatest minds in computer animation
research of its day from all over the
world in this small group in San Rafael
California was developing this
incredible technology and I was blown
away by this group and I said dad how
did you get all of these amazing people
you can see I had just come from Disney
that we're not quite interest that's not
the way we do it I kept hearing and he
said oh it's either easy I just try to
hire people that are smarter than myself
and I laughed and I walked away but that
statement I kept thinking about it and
saying that's a true leader someone
first ought to be smarter than this guy
hey he's pretty smart and so so but
that's you know and to get people but
also he let them be do what they were
great at and he let them shine and let
them become stars in in the computer
graphics world